PROFESSOR: So now, we can
summarize the safety guideline
in a very simple formula, using
the steady state transmission
rate as a more
conservative estimate
than worrying about the
transient buildup of aerosols
in the room, and using the
simplification of introducing
an effective size
for particles, R bar,
that includes and encodes
all the information
about the radius dependent
mass penetration factor
or sedimentation rate and
infectivity, et cetera,
in droplet size distribution.
And the safety guideline
looks like this.
It basically bounds the
cumulative exposure time,
which is n minus 1, the
number of susceptible people
when one person enters a room of
occupancy n, maximum occupancy,
and stays for a time tau.
And I should mention
the time tau does not
need to be continuous.
So if you think of, say,
a classroom or an office,
you will be adding up
the time, total time.
So if this safe
time is 100 hours
and you spend 10
hours a day, you
might get 10 days, according
to this calculation.
And so that relationship is
plotted as this yellow curve.
And if you're below
that curve, you're safe.
So you have either smaller time
than that or a lower occupancy.
And that's how you
can decide the safety.
Again, this is a safety
exposure guideline
for indoor airborne
transmission.
And we will talk about other
types of transmission later.
What's nice about
this formula is
it allows you to
immediately see the effects
of the scaling, some
of which we've already
talked about before.
So if we would like to
move it in this direction,
obviously, we would like the
curve to be up here somewhere.
So this is obviously
making the room more safe.
If I can push it
in this direction,
I can either get more
people or more time
or whatever combination
that I'd like.
How can I get there?
So Cq is a disease
specific parameter.
But we will see
that Cq does depend
on the type of respiration
and activities,
such as singing
or heavy exercise
or loud speaking are much worse
than resting or breathing.
So to get in this
direction, we could
do smaller Cq, which
could be resting
versus speaking or singing.
And we'll come back
to characterizing that
more carefully.
So we can at least change that
type of activity in the room.
Well for physical
parameters, we can
increase V, the room volume.
So if you take everything the
same, same number of people,
and you make the
room much bigger,
obviously the air
gets more diluted.
And hence, there's less
chance of transmission
if people are sort of
scattered about the room.
What else can we do?
We can lower Qb, which means
breathe slowly or in a more
relaxed way.
So again, coming
back to the activity
in the room, if you have
heavy physical exercise,
your Qb might increase, although
it doesn't increase that much.
Resting breathing is around
0.5 meters cube per hour.
And even heavy exercise
doesn't get much higher
than about 3 meters
cubed per hour.
And so that's a total
of a factor of 6 or so.
But it comes in squared.
So that could actually
be significant.
So definitely heavy exercise
is not as good as resting.
And what else do we have?
We have masks.
Well, obviously,
we can wear masks.
And that is actually
very helpful,
because as we've already
discussed, it comes in squared.
And that is something which
is sort of very simple fix.
And if the mask
penetration factor
is 10% or even possibly
less, it comes in squared.
So that can have a very big
effect of pushing this over,
as we will see.
So this is basically
lower P mask.
So when there's no
mask, Pm is equal to 1.
Finally we also
have an lambda C,
because we had written
that out earlier,
that also includes
several effects,
such as better ventilation.
So increase ventilation, so
the flow rate of outside air,
so the air change rate
should be increased.
And that gives us
a larger lambda C.
We can introduce air filtration.
And that's sort of
buried within lambda C.
That's PF lambda F. Although
as we discussed earlier,
because you have to have a
certain amount of fresh air
coming into the room, air
filtration doesn't give you
as much benefit
as you might hope,
but can still give you a
factor of 5 or something
like that if you have 20%
outdoor fresh air coming in.
And so those are some
of the key scalings
that we can understand.
And just simply by plugging
into a formula like this,
we can get a sense of how
different mitigation strategies
can be compared and also
how different types of rooms
can be compared in terms
of the occupancy time
and the number of
people that could be
allowed as a maximum occupancy.
And what remains now is the
parameterize this for COVID-19
specifically, which boils down
to understanding this parameter
Cq.